erich von stein on joe rogan number 13
twenty such an incredible conversation
between the two and we're gonna unpack
the nuance of what was discussed one of
the first things i was talked about was
how the real world is a very noisy place
to think and so Eric talked about his
preference in living in abstractions and
then checking back in to see if the real
world is actually governed by those
abstractions Eric talked about if he's
in an unstimulating conversation he'll
just play with people and the the great
danger is complacency always
experiencing change and growth always
playing and experimenting doing
something totally different from time to
time the IDW right now is like the
adults in the room as the kids are
running riot and there's been a societal
pressure cooker to form something like
this this this grounded group in nuance
in open heartedness in truth and
equanimity and in multivariate analysis
on these complex topics rather than the
cognitive musing binary tribalism echo
chambers that exists then Joe and Eric
talked about how there are actually now
significant BOTS that are acting as
players on the Internet and we talked
about this with dr. Nicholas Christakis
on our show as well where we talked
about his human nature lab and how he
was doing things like potentially
increasing the amount of cooperation
happening online well you can add BOTS
into the online conversation sphere to
be positive to increase empathy to
increase cooperation to increase nuance
well there's also BOTS that can make
people more toxic make people more
binary more cognitive ease more
tribalism more echo chambers more hatred
and so we need to be very careful about
who we actually engage with in these
common threads and if we even choose to
engage in the common thread sometimes we
can stay focused on our own North Star
and our own divine paths of creativity
this is a very interesting field to
think about and to be very and have a
deep amount of critical thinking about
these BOTS and algorithms that could
potentially be pushing people in certain
countries away from their North Star
journeys and towards this these pits of
distraction in these Joker vortexes
so what malevolent forces could
potentially be at play in the internet
sphere that we're actually not even
aware of that we need to do deeper
investigations and and what is the
spiritual fragmentation within people in
those countries that's causing and even
in our own that's causing us to want to
cast the malevolent attacks around the
world to distract people from their
North Star journey so we can prop up our
own economies let's be real we're all on
this rock together and that we need to
be working together and not distracting
each other with these types of
malevolence --is we need to be have our
own deep spiritual wholeness and help
each other with that spiritual wholeness
that divine communion with all that is
with God with source and then we won't
have the malevolence --is that we cast
into our world as BOTS that are trying
to separate us instead to try and bring
us together
we also heard Joe and Eric talk about
how it was interesting to have
discernment between whether or not it's
more conducive towards discourse to have
just a two person Joe with the guest or
Eric with the guest on their programs or
ourselves as well with us plus a guest
or sometimes when we bring in a second
or a third person to the conversation
and Eric made it clear that sometimes
it's like jazz performances really good
performances musical artists or any type
of even interlocutors in dialogue that
if done really well they can actually
draw out profound things from the
conversation or have a profound musical
quartet for example or trio yet we've
also seen people accidentally step
on each other and interrupted when
there's maybe really good flow happening
so again this is a really cool ideas who
would be a good third pillar to have
brought into that that Eric plus a Joe
dialogue could have there been a good
third pillar maybe it was just for an
hour and a half and then they left or
something so it's always interesting
food for thought there then also Eric
enjoy talked about how men manage
intimacy and closely closeness and how
men kind of [ __ ] on each other a lot
crack a lot of jokes at each other which
is really fun and also it's important
for men to also become vulnerable and to
become more intimate with each other and
express that love and compassion and
deep open-heartedness with each other
which in many ways society does not
foster that men like to make sure that
we're not taking ourselves too seriously
when we crack these jokes at each other
why not and there's different this is
another interesting difference between
men and women women have a different
methodology in many ways of managing
intimacy and closeness and that's very
beautiful and we need to appreciate that
about each other and see where these
things can overlap maybe some of the
joking tendencies of men can help women
become more joking but also maybe some
of the closeness and intimate tendencies
of women can come and help men as well
open-heartedness compassion love empathy
all right in many ways normal life is
unwell it's both gorgeous
but it's also unwell it's a very
interesting dichotomy and so this
creative process that basically we look
at something and we say that that can
become that can be totally better and
then we ourselves go through this burden
of genius about taking something on our
backs to augment something in our world
that transcends us for generations to
come and when you're that creative that
you're constantly looking at things and
you're swimming and ideas and you always
want to improve things
some people can look at that and be like
that's a mental health issue but it's
actually not it's actually one of the
most beautiful creative expressions of a
human being possible we need to start
treating it that way as
i D Eric talked about multiple times how
he's left the planet I thought this was
very interesting and that how his new
podcast called the portal actually helps
people that are trapped in this ordinary
world find a portal which is a call to a
journey a call to spend time in a new
universe and then when they come back
they've returned with this worldview
augmentation that they can then go and
share with other people and inspire
those people in a sense this platform 9
and 3/4 that we can kind of go and
venture into and then see the world in a
new way and then have this be a call to
journey have it be something that
excites us tremendously and then for us
to go and and have a way that we've
built a better world and then go and
share that with other people that's such
a beautiful thing he gave examples of
some of these portals
he said Antoni gaudí's la sagrada
familia and Barcelona is a portal that
was a very beautiful way of putting it
and that's really true cuz Gaudi focused
on religion nature and architecture and
combining the divine with architecture
in nature and I thought that was a
really beautiful way of putting it you
can see the columns in Sagrada família
are like massive trees and also Salvador
Dali somebody apparently asked him do
you take drugs and he said I am drugs
maybe maybe that's how that happened
that'd be very funny if that is because
the persistence of memory and also the
dream caused by the flight of a
bumblebee around a pomegranate a second
before awakening or just gorgeous
gorgeous the way they synthesize and
artistically express is gorgeous and
some people are in psychedelic states
all the time and you can kind of see
this with some of Alex Grey's artwork as
well I think that's a very beautiful
thing to have someone that's constantly
in those states of divinity of
interconnectedness of artistically
expressing themselves and those people
are actually the most well in such an
unwell world
so the ordinary life that it sometimes
seems that we live is actually insanely
epic and we need to put this mysticism
back in to our lives and also treat it
like science and spirituality are can
more closely harmonize with each other
so there was a really good chunk of time
that Eric went deep into math and
physics and I thought this part was
really interesting because we had just
had clear win' on the show for our
second round and he's doing very similar
work we're trying to figure out what's
going on with space-time and quantum
mechanics and the marriage of those two
and basically by doing that we can
potentially unlock the ultimate nature
of our reality at a deeper lesson that's
that in itself as a portal that's a call
to journey and when we get deep into
that we can potentially unlock a lot of
other ways of maximizing our prosperity
around the world and it was interesting
when they did the breakdown you know
from real numbers to complex numbers to
quaternions to octo nians to set onions
and so I'm trying to understand these a
little bit better and better but really
a lot of it is about getting deeper and
deeper into the most smallest
measurements of existence and in a sense
when you look at an atom and then you
look at the quarks and the electrons and
then when you look at the Planck volume
and then you just keep going and what
are that what is this pixelation of this
fabric of reality that we live in what
is that pixelation of it and can it
actually be described in mathematical
terms and physics terms and then can it
even further then be simulated these are
very profound questions that are a
massive call to journey that we can
inspire more young kids to get involved
in and there's so many other nuances
here the way that the Kaylie Dickinson
construction applies to this the way
that the difference is between
the Li groups the what's the difference
between a commutative and a non
commutative or an associative and a non
associative system these are fascinating
things and there's still so much to be
discovered here and we need more
people's attention on it and this
actually also calls to me a lot because
really how badly do you want to
understand God how badly do you want to
understand source the ultimate nature of
our reality because really if you want
to understand it in many ways it's a
beautiful thing to endeavor into the
deepest math and physics that exists and
so maybe this is a calling for me and
for calling for many other people is
that if we want to understand the
ultimate nature of our reality let's
dive deeper into the deepest math and
physics out there
they also circled back a little bit into
what is a principle bundle part of
foundational framework of gauge theory
and how that relates to the hopf
fibration which was talked about on
round two with Eric and Joe so there are
just so many edges of knowledge for
civilization to focus on that would
unlock massive superpowers and this is a
massive invitation for us humans it's a
huge invitation for us to unlock what
are the most deepest parts of the nature
of our reality and then for us to be
invited in a sense out of the planet and
into source code of reality and I'm
really happy that Eric also broke down
the C elegans as well
and it was really cool that sydney
brenner actually established this as a
model organism for the investigation of
developmental biology because it has its
whole genome sequence it's a thousand
cell organism with this whole genome
sequence its whole connectome which is
this neural wiring diagram completed
that's about 300 neurons and so we can
learn a tremendous amount because we are
a multi tens of trillion organism
cell organism and it's really difficult
for us to be able to understand the full
whole genome sequence and wiring diagram
of how everything works together here
and in our brains but with the C elegans
we already did that a thousand cell
organism a three hundred and our own
organism so we can actually see these
architectural plans of that organism and
we can investigate it more deeply as the
simplest place for us to understand
complex life in that this is another
portal the C elegans is another portal
it's another invitation to dive into the
complexity of our world and for inferred
more children around the world and
adults around the world to get in
excited about things like this grand
unification theory like the C elegans
like understanding developmental biology
another invitation that Erica mentioned
was the anomalous magnetic dipole moment
the quantum electrodynamics and quantum
field theory and how we have this
incredible analysis that we've done down
to ten significant figures of this
contribution of quantum mechanic effects
so can we really do things with
objective scientific empirical trial
sigh pollicis understandings versus what
seems to be in many ways this subjective
social engineering of conversation and
that's another massive thing that Eric
mentioned is that if you're coming after
my understanding of core reality this
scientific but also mystical love for
exploring and understanding the world if
you're coming at our lab where we're
trying to understand are the NH of our
reality with these social engineering
ways of manipulating the way we
understand our reality that we're gonna
call security and we're gonna get you
out of our lab and that we don't have to
have inclusion for the ideologies that
you're trying to bring in that maybe if
you're coming into our lab and you're
saying that well why is there no one
that is a woman or why is there no one
that is handicapped or why is there no
one that is from Cambodia inside of your
lab well maybe I don't need to address
that question maybe I can just keep
hanging out with the people that are at
the cutting edge of physics no matter
what I don't care if they're Cambodian
or female or if they're handicapped or
not I want the cutting edge people in
physics or in blockchain technology or
in brain science studies I want those
people no matter what skin color
religion no matter what they are
although we also understand there's a
principle of inclusion that's important
it's the nuance again where you might
have someone from Cambodia or that's a
woman or that's handicapped that can
bring an interesting realization to the
way that we study one of these fields
and just don't you dare bring in some of
the social engineering conversations
that you're trying to have about our
world where you're actually putting at
risk our beautiful science journal and
the way that we're trying to understand
the ultimate nature of our reality so in
a sense the portal is things like
Sagrada família Doc Toni ins Kaylie
graphs principal bundle C elegans and
then that in comparison to things like
gender studies where you have things
that are basically not even empirically
reviewed entering into scientific
journals really look at those two things
feel them in your essence where does
society need to have more of its focus
on unlocking the next portals that give
us a deeper understanding the ultimate
nature of our reality
so again as important as inclusion is
exclusion is just as important
discernment I don't owe you the time of
day again another really good example is
maybe there are certain Russians that
are just beasts at producing pianist or
chess players and that it's not unfair
or same thing with in athletics even
though that there can be a significant
amount of black people that are
successful at basketball or football or
other sport that we're not gonna say
that that's unfair and that we need to
enter in more Latinos or more Asian
people into those sports to make it fair
no you let the meritocracy roll is there
structural oppression it's not
everything it's not structural
oppression but there may be some because
hierarchies can sometimes have
tyrannical aspects to them and we need
to investigate those more deeply again
it's about the nuance so Eric and Joe
talked a lot about this interest in this
pipeline of amazing portals that are
low-hanging fruits and keeping the
culture wars out of distracting us from
hard progress it's so important what are
the portals into the lowest hanging
fruits that we can even sometimes the
higher hanging fruits that we can then
go and adventure into as a journey as a
civilization and keep the culture wars
out of that so we can make effective
progress Eric talked a lot about how he
likes doing isolated things in the
absence of other people that have a very
technical nature to them which in many
ways so many of us have two that we like
to be alone that we like to dive deep
into the technical sides of the things
that we're studying and synthesize and
spend time alone from other people and
in many ways men are making sacrifices
to do things like that a lot but also
women like to be more with other people
they like to socialize more they like to
be with children more and raise children
and be with elderly care as well and be
with them more and we need to understand
that release
but maybe there is something we need to
do to help fund women these next steps
into the STEM fields when they are very
interested in them because they also
have this proclivity to want to raise
kids and have family and whatnot as well
Wow men just are just hardcore focused
on their specific thing and just
sacrificing everything to do that so
that's a focus on kin work for women
much of the time and air gave the
anomaly of women in the 1950s that were
successful in stem they had husbands
that also made a lot of money so they
had a nanny to free them of some of the
drudgery so they could focus on stem so
again it's about the multivariate
analysis so Eric que ma JRE and
showcased these most important fields
for children and adults to pursue to
enter into portals and push the edge of
knowledge Eric also mentioned how he
likes people outside the norms and how
sometimes there is an ambiguity to
gender or sex like with intersex people
and how we need to be careful that it
could be something that feels like an
oppression to people that don't fit into
that normal male-female binary and also
the fact that evolution is a constantly
ongoing process and that we can't just
dig ourselves into a specific rut of a
way that we think I also really like
people that are outside of the norms I
find them way more interesting than
people that have had the same experience
as everyone else they talked about how
activism doesn't necessarily make for
good advancement that it needs
objectivity and that there are no bad
words there is bad intent that we can
build a skepticism around the AC tees
SATs and IQ and how it is in a sense of
proxy for intelligence but that we've
met people with low IQs that blow us
away there's creative intelligences
emotional intelligence spatial
intelligence so many other forms of
intelligence so we need to stop the
crowding out of the multivariate
analysis with the cognitive eased
arguments so where we have binary
thinking that's trying to be really loud
about complex multivariate issues we
need to just say get out of our lab
get out of our lab we're calling
security because we need to focus on the
real truth the multivariate analysis in
calculating these things and Eric and
Joe talked about how in a sense there
are sometimes like Country Club
Republicans are sympathetic to the
far-right and meanwhile the left is
sympathetic to a antifa
and how in a sense they're trying to say
that that that group is not being taken
care of and so it is these fringes that
are trying to take care of those groups
and so I need my organized crime group
to get rid of yours and I thought that
was a very interesting way of looking at
it but we need the middle and we need
the middle left in the middle right to
work together in this multivariate
analysis in the lab the truth-seeking
and then to just keep the fringes in
more peaceful circumstances while we do
that analysis we can't keep pushing
ordinary human beings to the extremes we
need more middle people to step up
courageously we need to keep the
pipeline open for science stop choosing
activism over civility you can't build a
world on angry activism we need
cross-pollination of ideas between other
groups we need to access the neuronal
infrastructure in so many people around
the world that could creatively endeavor
and build cool things so meeting the
basic needs of humans so they can
creatively endeavor and bring their
gifts of the world is so critical and
then ending on how we have to leave this
planet how we started a clock around
1953 with the first hydrogen bomb
explosion of figuring out the double
helix this twin nuclei problem we don't
have the wisdom to fuse nuclei or
investigate the cell we are now gods but
for the wisdom we are now gods before
the wisdom and when we interviewed max
tegmark on our show he called it the
wisdom race and how the democratization
of exponential technologies are now
becoming more and more ubiquitous and
Mileva tential EEMA not malevolent while
simultaneously our wisdom is not
catching up fast enough we don't realize
the divine beauty of us cohabiting this
play
together and now we can't have things
like Putin and Trump that are in so many
ways not temperamentally fit to have the
secrets of theoretical physics so many
of the world leaders are just not temper
mentally fit to have these secrets at
their fingertips and just to cascade
whatever styles of malevolence that they
want around the world on other people so
we need to diversify and spread
ourselves out yes earth yes underground
yes into space yes into them onto the
Moon and Mars but we also need to
understand the source code of our
reality and that the big questions
around particle theory being based on
geometry that the purpose of the portal
Eric's new show in so many ways is to
galvanize the world around the next
steps in understanding the ultimate
nature of our reality we need to take
arms against the sea of troubles that we
face and we need to ask these massive
questions does something unprecedented
happen when we finally learn our own
source code that was Eric's last
question on the edge does something
unprecedented happen when we finally
learn our own source code such a great
question and asking those big questions
the biggest questions ever what built
reality who are we what is the point of
this and what's the source code of this
ask each other those questions ask our
families ask ourselves these questions
more often ask people online these
questions these big questions are the
ones that can more easily bring humanity
together we need to really be careful
with the amount of distractions that we
have as we focus on these questions it's
going to be entertaining but we have to
focus in our labs around these questions
and we are all scientists we are all
spiritual we all have to figure out how
to
focus in on these big questions and on
to bringing our gifts into the world and
helping others bring their gifts into
the world and to figure out how to
cohabit this planet together more
peacefully with more love and with more
proclivity towards the big questions of
science and spirituality who built this
why we're here
alright that's it that's been a nice
synthesis on Eric's recent appearance on
Joe Rogan number 1320 thanks everyone
for tuning in I greatly appreciate it
your host of the show simulation Alan
sockin you find all of our great
interviews with leaders from around the
world from different fields the edge of
their fields on this channel and also
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the leaders around the world that you
believe and support them and help them
grow all of our links are below support
us help us grow to have more of these
conversations with people that we talked
about in this episode and that Joe and
Eric talked about too much love thank
you so much for tuning in and also guys
plant trees this tree right here I
planted 11 years ago with my mother look
at how big it is now it's now providing
me with shade we're gonna plant some
more trees again highly recommend it's a
very spiritual exercise and it also
connects us to things that transcend us
so do that plant the tree guys watch it
grow so long term delayed gratification
it's beautiful
thanks everyone for tuning in see you
soon peace